mark about grocery shopping eat again oh
we are way to be rude yeah we would say
cop cops yes okay k corsage I'd say it's
a supermarket oh yeah say to stay up
okay so do you remember how to say I'm
going or I go grocery shopping okay you
can save a dog supermercado okay when
you say I'm getting my groceries until
you say vado a far it nasty so it's for
a burger I'm dying so i'm not creepy I'm
gonna end up sorry oh la la spesa and
that it is an irregular very very
different 30 okay so let's try to review
it we say yo yo Dom Vince 0 2 y by the
fact of play is bad but yes
do you ever why I'm putting the subject
in parentheses c0 unless you really want
to emphasize now you're upset bottle yo
are firing a spacer because too numb by
Eldora follow him why don't you say yoga
that's it would be fine say yo mother
fell asleep but really want to emphasize
it I am going it's not bad you find a
space which implies not you okay Sam
yeah yeah Mon C on yahoo wow you
remember everything I'm about Jamie baby
scream oh yeah it's about don't ruin the
magic oh come on you have one left
example it has to do with the be its
with the BTS fun but why romney won
difficult but I know like uh no okay so
let's try try to really fill up yes
Laura come on yahoo a finalist phases we
have different options possiamo andare
al supermercado supermercado is the big
grocery store like you would find super
nakato
yep that's okay lenka top or maybe you
prefer to the grocery shopping in
smaller shops so you have different
options makati city yes that is in
mankato but you know what is in mankato
like the farm yeah the difference is
that the farmers market usually you can
put stuff but it's kind of expensive if
you get to god I'm mankato the new
traits good start it's not super
expensive every town or every
neighborhood has a day of the week when
there is email cattle for example in my
hometown unikkatil at the sabbath of
martina which day yes even it's always
in the morning so when I go visit I
always try to be there Saturday morning
cuz I love going there you get the best
fruits vegetables the best cheese
everything and and you don't find out
the food we also find clothes and shoes
bring your kind of some pizza if you go
to visit some place either should check
when is in that pattern well then you
can you have different options there are
small shops that sell food from the duck
call a demain time 1230 time yes anyway
I and they tend to be a little bit more
expensive for some specific sorts of
food you would go in a specific shop so
if you want to buy valium by Al panel
features funny each of
honey feature funny feeling hi Egypt do
you want my meat you are like my left
community is where they actually make it
but what it will be much in aisle in
this store wouldn't you be the match
Olivia yes yeah but it yeah the much
alike is the first I'm sorry I got
distracted much alidium busting area no
we don't discuss today is this must be
Julia past you want to buy pastries
you're going fast each hmm now you know
how to make that so you don't need to
know about seafood bisque area and this
space k near and you can get permits a
possible and the cast oh yeah or you're
going to go to the multi-line don't even
root people routinely okay so you have a
lot of different options when another
thing that you should keep in mind is
that both is super mercapto and the
smaller Madoc see the gong show is a
store can you negotiate a lot I've
always I don't have okay you may go to
paradise in a coffee so most super
McCarty and legacy they're usually not
open light here twenty-four-seven so
typically they close if you're lucky and
a PM earlier they might be closed on
Sunday
sometimes our clothes on like monday or
wednesday on some cities they have
different tastes yeah then another thing
is that in a goth scene usually their
close-ups and lunge so there are another
few things that you should know you
should go a super McCallum anytime
tomorrow it's great one thing is that
you need to bring with you a fine of
that good a bro or do it Emily what I'm
joking we don't we always say able I
don't conjugate the point on a roadway
Europe but you need a coin with a
modicum Cottrell you know oh yeah see
what is the current of the cartographer
yes for shopping another thing that's
important is that they say a super
mankato if I could have hooked up over
Dora okay they provide you with gloves
my love for items you can't just touch
things you have to wear these plastic
blocks and then you can pick your hooked
up and then put up and then you also
have to wait it and then I price it
yourself and one last thing haha nobody
will help you make direct the swetha
name or sarcastic what did I say
nobody's going to help you to fill that
space up groceries need sacchetto
Edinburgh well so you either bring your
own Sacchetti or what you do you can get
them at the supermarket and repay them
they are not expensive remember if your
sentence but the idea is that so people
do not use too many plastic bags but if
you pay cecchetto you still have to the
groceries on your own yeah okay one last
thing let's say that and yahoo super
mankato supermercado chi sono nicosia
and then she saw no aunty productive
what is the party but I mean I got a
superb account of check company feature
whenever chain area the face is Korea ok
so there are different sectors of the
supermarket about gravity departed so
let's say that you want a hundred grams
because you have to use bronze Oh for
hot job lot of tournaments run try to
grab me instead of saying check togami
we would say porner at top
you know I throw in the traffic's that
you use for a hundred with each other so
go grab me would be porn actor so I
think it's good to have in mind this
will be your asking I would like
touching the ground many / me down with
our family what I teach em to grammys
are made under power then they may
answer today keep your life no look at
me it is simply the change is so that is
too much it's so low